From somewhere
deep within
The vastness
of Youtube.
A man come`th.
*epic music* [also wtf ken]
*epic music*
*epic music continues*
*more epic music*
*enough epic music cmon pweds*
*annoying epic music still continues*
*ENOUGH*
*ding dong*
Pewds: Who the f uck is that?
Ken: I think its me
Pewds: I'll check it out
hello?
who is it?
Ken: Hear ye, Hear ye
this message coming from the house of youtube
it's intended for the right honorable
Felix Arvid Ulf
kje-kje-elberg
also known as pewdiepie
we wish to express our deepest most profound
bropology for the delay of your diamond
play button award
It is not our wish to displease you or your formidable bro army
This is why I have provided you...
with your horse *neighs*
and glitter
*popping noise*
*such wows and excitement*
And now [tense moment]
For your diamond play button [TENSE MOMENT]
Pewds: Finally
It's about damn time
THE DIAMOND PLAY BUTTON O:
*Felix gasps in exaggerated surprise*
The legends were true !
It exists !
Oh my! (how ladylike Felix is)
*grunts*
So heavy
YES !
FINALLY !
*music changes to display conflict*
*Felix rubs his (ken's) play button
*sexy tongue movements*
*Felix rubs some more while zommed in*
Ken: My precious
Pewds: CinnamonToastKen !
You son of a bitch!
How dare you show your face around these parts!
Ken: I'm here to claim what's mine !
The Diamond play button
*awkward noises while fighting music plays*
*ken gets away :(*
*pewds whistles to summon satan edgar to smite Ken*
*unicore replies instead*
*dramatic unicorn? music*
*dramatic music intensifies with gunshots in background*
Pewds: Geet bahck heer Kehn you son ov a beech
That's mah playh button
*shattering noise* (Pewd's heart and the diamond play button)
NOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOOO
*exaggerated crying*
HOW COULD YOU DO THIS ?
AHHHHH
*sad music :(*
*creepy old man*
How could this happen ?
YouTube
I have one last wish (he never stops does he ?) (no he doesn't.
Gimme another play button
And I will forgive your sins
*Zapping noise as the YouTube Gods have mercy on him*
*Delighted OH*
*end credits music*
YEAAAH !
*end credits music continues* lol
*sudden stop*